y te cuento que yo soy un poco
contraria a lo que son las las metáforas
bélicas con la enfermedad sobre todo
porque creo que las mujeres que no
sobreviven al cáncer de mama no son
menos luchadoras o menos guerreras creo
que la verdad es que la noticia que te
aviso en que tenés que que te digan que
algo no salió bien en el estudio y que
tenés cáncer de mama es realmente un
baldazo de agua fría es muy duro nadie
se lo espera nadie está preparada para
recibir esa noticia y cada una la
atraviesa atraviesa la enfermedad como
puede como le sale y bueno y básicamente
es poner el cuerpo una y otra vez es
poner el cuerpo para la mamografía es
poner el cuerpo el cuerpo para para la
punción para esperar el resultado
esperar el resultado es difícil es duro
y cuando te dan la noticia es poner el
cuerpo para la operación poner el cuerpo
para el tratamiento pero bueno se sale
eso ya estoy cumpliendo tres años
del diagnóstico y del tratamiento y
bueno y la verdad es que
quiero transmitir digamos que la
información y la enfermedad detectada
tiempo es la diferencia y cambia todo es
lo más importante la detección temprana
es fundamental
nunca hay algo más importante que hacer
de los estudios o escucha a veces te
dicen algunas mujeres no tengo tiempo no
puedo estar ocupada no hay nada más
importante que eso porque es la
diferencia entre la detección temprana o
la detección de alumno tardía en mi caso
fue detección temprana y eso hizo que
fuera todo más fácil
marianna por lo que cuentas
emocionalmente entonces fue lo más duro
no afrontar esta enfermedad pues también
luchar la con la mente
sí sí porque yo me di cuenta
al tener el diagnóstico los prejuicios
que existen con el cáncer
y cáncer muchas veces para mucha gente y
yo creo que para mí también antes era
sinónimo de muerte era era como una
sentencia de muerte
y me doy cuenta que no es así y me doy
cuenta que es una enfermedad que es una
enfermedad difícil que es una enfermedad
que tiene una carga muy muy dura y muy
fuerte pero no es sinónimo de muerte hay
mucho para hacer por suerte hay la
ciencia avanzó mucho en esto hay muy
buenos profesionales hay que saber pedir
ayuda y se sale adelante pero los
prejuicios que existen con el cáncer
también son difíciles a mí me pasaba que
por ahí le contaba alguna gente que
tenía cáncer y me miraban con cara como
de despedida más o menos que me estaban
velando y es muy difícil eso a veces el
entorno también tiene que estar a la
altura y tiene que informarse para poder
acompañar como como la persona que está
atravesando la enfermedad leonesas lo
necesitan